BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any of you
out there would like to ask
questions--
LOUIS GRAY: Good afternoon.
This is Louis Gray here, with
Google Developers Live.
We've started a little bit late,
but we're really excited
here to go ahead and
talk with you and
introduce you to Don Dodge.
He's a developer advocate in the
Developer Relations team
for Google.
My name's Louis Gray, as
I mentioned before.
I run Google Developers Live.
And between the two of us, Don
and I have had a lot of
experience not only working at
startups, but working with
startups, covering startups,
talking to
people who do startups.
And it might not seem the case
because Google is such a large
company, but we really are
especially interested in
entrepreneurship, VC investing,
angel investing,
and finding out what are the
next applications, services,
and people to really make a
difference in technology.
So I wanted to see if--
Don, you can have
an opportunity
to introduce yourself.
DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge.
I work at Google Developer
Relations.
And I work with startups mostly,
all across the world.
I live in Boston area and work
in Mountain View and travel
all over the world to find
the most exciting
startups that we can find.
LOUIS GRAY: And how did you
end up at Google, Don?
DON DODGE: Well most
people know me from
Microsoft or Google.
I worked at Microsoft and did
a similar job there in
Developer Relations and worked
with startups and venture
capital people.
I was there for five years,
and now I'm at Google
Developer Relations doing
a similar job.
And I've been here
for three years.
The interesting thing though, is
most of my career was spent
at startups.
I was involved in six of them.
And most of my career
was with startups.
Yet most people know me from
Microsoft or Google.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
That's pretty common, as you
can understand, with people
paying so much attention to
the big companies like
Microsoft and Google who make
a lot of the products
we use every day.
It's easy to know you from
the big visibility.
But the startup world is
very interesting space.
I used to say that Google is the
biggest startup I've ever
worked for.
There's a lot of things about
Google which feel like a
startup, and other things that
feel like a big company.
And so there are definitely
attributes to working on small
teams, starting with incredible
ideas, and trying
to innovate, that define
what a startup is.
As someone who has gone through
successful and maybe
less successful startups, as I
have, it would be interesting
to get your take a
little bit on--
first, what a difference
is between a
startup and a big company?
When do you know you've
passed that threshold?
And then second, what are some
of those ingredients that make
a startup grow to
the next level?
DON DODGE: Interesting.
"Startup" is a overused term,
and not very well-defined.
Startups can be two people
or 200 people, and
maybe as large as 2,000.
But most times, people think
of startups being less than
three years old, less than a
couple of million in revenue,
and probably less than
50 employees.
That's what I tend to think
of as a startup.
But there are much larger
companies that work like a
startup and act like a startup,
so it's not an easy
thing to define.
LOUIS GRAY: And we talked about
the transition from that
startup phrase to what we call--
be it a young company,
the "growth" phase.
Sometimes I often see people
make the mistake of confusing
public companies versus private
companies as being a
definition for a startup.
You look at companies like
Twitter and Facebook, for
example, who were in the private
phase for a lot longer
than was traditional.
Maybe 10 years ago, you would
see people go public before
they had profitability.
You would see companies go
public just after they started
achieving revenue.
And it looks like these other
companies like Facebook and
Twitter had made a conscious
decision to avoid the public
market scrutiny, to avoid some
of the Sarbanes-Oxley
requirements that were there
because those requirements
have changed.
Do you find that you can
actually act like a startup
when you're a public company?
Or maybe there are private
companies that have already
moved beyond that stage and just
can be continuous, but
don't label themselves
as startups?
DON DODGE: Yeah, that's
a good point.
I think the lines have blurred
between startup, and regular
company, and private company,
and public company.
So the lines have
blurred a bit.
For me, the difference is if
you're profitable, you're
probably no longer a startup.
So I just look at, are you a
profitable company or not?
And if you're profitable,
then you're out
of the startup phase.
Whether you're public or not
is a different matter.
LOUIS GRAY: You know, I worked
at a company for eight and a
half years, a company
called BlueArc.
It was a network storage
provider.
And when I first joined, they
were at first customer ship
phase, very exciting.
We launched.
We got coverage from The Wall
Street Journal, and The New
York Times, and all of
the technology rags.
And then for the next eight
years, we went through a
number of phases--
first customer ship to
first product, second
product, third product.
We filed for IPO, we withdrew.
We filed for IPO again.
And from eight years through, it
was like there were things
about us that were
startup-like.
But we hadn't achieved
profitability yet.
And you had to constantly try
to fight and have people
understand that you
were viable.
And it was interesting-- just to
put an endcap on that, they
actually were acquired by
Hitachi Data Systems last year
for more than half a
billion dollars.
And you'd say, well, were
they ever profitable?
No, they weren't.
They were achieving
profitability maybe in a
quarter, but not for
the full year.
But I think it would be hard to
challenge them and say they
were a startup because they
weren't profitable.
I think it's hard to tie
those two together.
DON DODGE: Oh sure.
There are lots of public
companies that are not
profitable either.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
And some divisions within the
company you mentioned--
Microsoft has often tried a lot
of work on their online
services side and never
made a profit.
And it's interesting to look
at acting like a startup
within a big company.
And you let revenue from one
part of the company really
take advantage of the other
pieces that are more
innovative.
And maybe you can take more risk
with places that you want
to take new markets on.
As someone like yourself,
you've come to Google.
You interact still with startups
on a regular basis.
I know you've been a judge on
TechCrunch, Disrupt, and a
number of other things.
Where do you see your role in
terms of the rest of the
community outside of
the Googleplex?
DON DODGE: Well most of my work
is with startups, and has
been for virtually
all of my career.
So I've either worked in
startups or worked with
startups my entire life.
Sometimes Microsoft is paying my
paycheck, and now Google is
paying my paycheck.
But my job is working with
startups, and helping them be
successful, and finding some
interesting startups that
might want to partner with
Google or maybe become a part
of Google as an acquisition.
So for me, my whole life
has been startups.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
Now one thing we talked about
before we went on the air-- we
were talking about those things
that intrigue you,
either as an angel investor or
even a blogger to try and
cover these guys.
I've never been lucky enough to
have the revenue available
to become an angel investor.
But I always saw myself, as a
blogger, you'd kind of be the
VC arm for free.
Like I was always super excited
about a product.
And I would talk about all day,
and let people know that
this is going to be something.
And it's kind of fun to look
back at things like
MightyText, and [? Fee Lee, ?]
and TweetDeck, and
social media.
And some of these products that
have gone from where I
was covering them first-ever on
the blog, and seeing them
become viable companies or
products that have hundreds of
thousands or even tens
of millions of users.
What is it about a product
or a service that
really sparks your idea?
And you say, that's something
I want to invest in.
Or that's something I want
to tell everybody about?
DON DODGE: Well first it has
to be something that I
understand and can use.
So that's probably
the first gate.
If I don't understand what it
is-- if it's too complicated
for me or in an area I don't
really understand, then I'm
probably not going to get
excited about it.
I've said it for a long time--
investors invest in companies
that are in a business they
understand or they're led by
people that they know.
If you don't know the people and
you don't understand the
business, then the chances
of investing
are pretty near zero.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
And now you mention people--
I think we could talk
about whether--
teams versus ideas-- and I
think we'll get to that.
But from being connected and
networked as you are, I think
we both see that we have friends
that are established
at Company A. And they
may go off and
start their own startup.
They might regroup as
a team, and you find
them somewhere else.
Do you automatically say, look,
I'm going to invest in
this guy because I know he's
going to do a great job.
Maybe a good example is Mike
McHugh who went from Tellme
Networks and did Flipboard.
And there's a guy with
an established
track record of history.
You see serial entrepreneurs
kind of just have a success,
move, have another success,
have another success.
Do you ever get to the point
where you know-- like if Evan
Williams comes to you and
says, I'm going to start
something new, that you give him
money without even asking
with the product is, because
of their track record?
And what is it that defines that
kind of leadership that
you think can see through an
opportunity and make it happen?
DON DODGE: Yeah.
Those are good questions.
Serial entrepreneurs do tend
to be more successful than
first-time entrepreneurs.
They're about 30% or 40% more
likely to be successful than a
first-time entrepreneur.
But that's not always
the case.
Sometimes serial entrepreneurs
get too fat and happy, too
rich, and then they want to do
something that maybe they're
not totally, totally
committed to.
And that's probably not going
to be a good investment.
I've seen that happen
a couple of times.
But if you can catch an
entrepreneur on their second,
third, fourth company, you've
got a pretty good chance of
being successful.
LOUIS GRAY: Now usually
a startup--
and we talked about it being
as few as three people--
but it always starts with one
person with one idea.
I've see a lot of change in
the Valley in the 15 years
that I've been working here--
about what is critical
and what's important.
I think-- when I was first in
the Valley, I remember you'd
read like MacWEEK Magazine, a
and it seemed that everybody
wanted to be a webmaster.
And maybe three years ago,
everybody wanted to be a
social media expert.
And you've seen these waves kind
of come and go and find
out what's critical
to a startup.
What are the type of roles
that you see all sorts of
startups really just
overpaying for?
Or they're really, really
looking for talent and it's
hard to find.
Is it design?
Is it something on
the back-end?
What is it that you think
everybody is really just
hopping for right now, and why
do you think that's happening?
DON DODGE: Well I think
designers are
the new rock stars.
So you're right.
In the past, everyone wanted
to be a website developer.
And then a few years ago,
it was all social media.
Everybody wanted to do that.
And more recently, it's
a mobile developer--
or mobile games, mobile apps,
that kind of thing.
But what I'm seeing now is
designers are the key hire.
I've seen several companies
that I've invested in
personally, where they have a
great technical team, but they
struggle to find a designer.
And design is so important
in social applications--
much more so than
enterprise-type applications.
And great designers are really,
really hard to find.
LOUIS GRAY: What does a company
need to do to find
this kind of talent?
How do you try and prioritize
when you don't have a lot of
money to start with?
How you grow a team?
DON DODGE: You know, that's
a good question too.
I have people ask me, well, why
can't I be a sole founder?
Why do I have to have
several co-founders?
Or why do I have to have
technical people, or design
people, or business people,
or marketing people?
And the answer is that you
really only need the talent
that you need to get to
that next milestone.
Maybe it's a public beta.
Or maybe it's releasing
it for real.
But whatever talent that you
need to get to that level is
really all you need
for that time.
And it can be a different mix
of people as you go along.
But the key thing is, why do you
need more than one person
to start a company?
It's validation, really.
Investors rarely will invest
in a company that has one
founder and maybe a couple
of engineers.
The reason is, they're looking
for validation.
They want to know that you're
a leader that can attract
great talent.
If you can't convince a couple
of great people to drop what
they're doing and come join
you and your company, then
it's probably not a good idea.
So--
LOUIS GRAY: One of the things
that I ran into a lot--
I would be asked to cover a lot
of different events, be it
something like TechCrunch,
Disrupt, or 500
Startups, demo days.
And what was always interesting
is they had a very
explicit pitch--
here's what we're doing.
Here's the team that we have.
We're positioned in this market
that we know well.
And here's how much money
we're raising.
And I think a lot of times,
people get excited about the
press releases that say X
company has raised $1 million,
$5 million, $10 million,
whatever that is.
And obviously with tech blogging
being what it is,
it's rare that you see people
follow-up and go, what did you
do with that $5 million?
And what is that $5 million for
a hardware company versus
$5 million for a software
company, having lived through
a company that raised
a quarter billion
from venture capital.
But for hardware, I can
understand that the metrics
are a little bit different.
What do you think money from
investment should be going for
at different stages of
a company's life?
And then the second thing--
as an investor, what kind of
role do you think you play, as
opposed to just putting money
on a bet and hoping it comes
back 5 or 10X?
DON DODGE: Well, I think we've
seen recently startups raise
too much money.
And having too much money
is almost as bad
as having not enough.
If you have too much money,
you hire too many people.
You expand too quickly.
You don't have that
hungry, work all
night kind of attitude.
So as an investor, I would
rather invest a million or so
in a pre-revenue startup than
I would invest in a company
that's raising $10 million.
Because it's a whole
different dynamic.
The second thing is, as an
investor, I can add more value
to a small startup that's
pre-revenue and raising a
small amount of money than I
can a big company that's
raising $10 million
or $20 million.
So--
LOUIS GRAY: What kind of
impact do you mean?
Is it more than just the money
that you're providing?
Or what kind of advisor
role can you give?
What kind of introductions
can you do?
What are you supposed to do
after writing a check?
DON DODGE: Well I tell people
if I wanted to be a passive
investor, I would invest in
the stock market and just
invest in stocks.
I'm not a passive investor.
I'm an active investor
and try to add value.
So that means I'll help them
find other investors.
I'll help them find their
series A, B, C's.
I'll help them get introduced
to the press--
TechCrunch and VentureBeat and
PandoDaily, and all these
other outlets.
I'll help them find maybe
some executive talent.
Help them find a designer,
introduce them
to potential partners.
So it's those kinds of things
that are pretty important for
a startup when they're just
getting going, and less
important when they're on their
Series B and have raised
$20 million.
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah.
So I want to go back
a little bit.
We were talking about your
history with startups.
You didn't tell anybody
what those are.
Now I've known because we've
talked for some time.
And I think it's always
interesting to get behind--
behind the Microsoft, behind
the Google story, and
understand where you
were before that.
Maybe you can give us a little
bit of background on those
startups, and kind of talk about
either a success story
or a challenge story that came
out of any of those.
DON DODGE: Yeah.
I did five startups, which
was most of my career.
And only late in life did I
join a big company like
Microsoft or Google--
LOUIS GRAY: But you say "late in
life" as if you're on your
death bed, sir.
And I still see that your hair
is brown, and you're walking
around with vitality.
So I think it's not going to be
long where you say "most of
your life," because eventually,
Google will take
up the plurality
of your career.
DON DODGE: Yeah,
let's hope so.
I started working when
I was very young.
But the common thread through
all of the five startups that
I did was they were the
first of its kind--
the first time that this
technology had ever been done.
So it was bleeding edge
kind of stuff.
And I didn't plan it that way.
But once I did a couple of
startups, when I went to the
next one, it was always, OK--
is this leading edge stuff?
Is this breakthrough
kind of technology?
Is the startup team someone who
I really respect and I can
learn from?
Is it something new that
I haven't done before?
There's an interesting story.
I was--
one of the startups
was AltaVista.
It was the first real search
engine on the web.
And I was running the crawler
team and later
did multimedia search--
so searching for images, or
searching for music, or
searching for video.
And that had never
been done before.
So it was very exciting stuff.
And there was this tiny little
startup called "Google," and
Larry and Sergey were still
in their dorm room.
And I knew them then.
And I could have joined Google
12 years ago, right after
AltaVista, but you know
what I thought?
I've already done that.
I've done search.
We invented multimedia search.
And it just wasn't that
interesting to me.
So I didn't go to Google.
Instead, I went to Napster.
Because Napster was something
really new and interesting,
never been done before.
DON DODGE: Now what's
incredible, Don--
I have to stop you
for a second.
Some people who are watching
this video don't know what
Napster was.
I mean, I know that sounds wild,
because I was already
working in the Valley when
Napster was going on.
And it was quite controversial,
but also very
exciting as it changed
the game.
Tell us a little bit
about Napster.
DON DODGE: Right.
So let me back up a little
bit further.
AltaVista--
people might not know that.
But AltaVista was the first
search engine, the first
search engine of any size.
And it was the "Google"
of its day.
And this was back
in 1995, 1996.
So it was pretty
amazing stuff.
Napster was the first
music sharing site.
And it was a peer-to-peer kind
of environment where you could
share music with other
people, maybe people
you didn't even know.
And they could share
music with you.
It turned out to be, at least
determined by the courts, to
be illegal, and was shut down.
And it was the precursor of all
the music sharing sites
that are on the internet
today.
LOUIS GRAY: You know,
it's interesting.
I was actually working straight
out of college at a
little company called 3Cube.
And every time I say 3Cube,
people go, oh, I remember.
I heard about them.
And they're usually thinking
about 3Com, or C-Cube, or
something like that.
But 3Cube was in internet
communications.
And so we were doing things
like internet faxing--
remember back, faxing
was the thing.
We did conference calling.
And I still have yet to see a
product better than what we
offered back then.
It was called Phone Cube.
And you could literally get on
your computer and dial out up
to 8 or 32 participants
at once.
You had your address book
integrated, and you
could call them out.
And I remember talking to
my mother about it.
Because it wasn't something like
you grew up and you say I
want to work on internet
faxing.
But I talked to her, and all she
was worried about, like,
are you doing something
good that's
helpful for the community?
Are you being able to
make great products
and tools for users?
So long as I wasn't
doing evil--
I know it sounds funny,
Google, do no evil--
but so long as I wasn't doing
something that was bad, she
was happy for me.
And I kind of got
that feedback.
Like it really doesn't matter
what industry you're in,
whether you're in music sharing,
as you're saying, or
search engines, or internet
communications--
so long as you're doing good
for end-users and they're
seeing value.
And I knew that a lot of our
customers were really excited
about what we were able to do.
We didn't have a
ton of success.
And eventually the company's
assets were purchased by
Oracle, and folded into one
of their meeting suites.
But we felt really good
about our product.
We knew that the technology
was incredible, and we got
great feedback from users.
How do you know that you're
doing the right thing as a
startup, or even now?
How do you know that
you're providing a
high-quality product?
What kind of feedback
are you looking for?
DON DODGE: Well most of my
career in software, I worked
in obscurity, where no
one really understood
what we were doing.
I started my career in database
software, which is
arcane, back-end kind of
software that really isn't
visible to the public.
So most of the time, the work I
was doing, my parents had no
idea what I was doing.
And for most software
engineers, that's
the way life is.
You're working on things that
are not visible to the public
and not that well-known.
But underneath the covers can
be pretty amazing stuff.
And I think AltaVista
and Napster--
those two companies were the
first time in my career where
my mother actually understood
what I did.
That doesn't make it better.
As a matter of fact, from a
financial perspective, we
didn't make money on either
one of those companies.
They were very well-known and
used by millions of people,
but we didn't make any money.
LOUIS GRAY: The lawyers made
plenty of money, if I recall--
DON DODGE: Yeah.
The lawyers made a lot
of money on Napster.
LOUIS GRAY: So coming back to
the present day, we talked
about what angel investors
can do to help a company.
We talked about your approach
and what gets you interested.
If I'm a startup person-- if
I've just got a great idea or
a great product--
what can I do to reach out,
either to you or other angel
investors or other VCs?
What is it that I need to do
to get their attention?
DON DODGE: It's really easier
than you might imagine.
Robert Scovill posts his cell
phone number on his website.
And you can call him, you
can tweet to him.
You can put a message on
his Facebook page.
He's pretty accessible.
And most of us are.
LOUIS GRAY: But Robert's
not a VC.
And he's not an angel
investor either.
DON DODGE: No.
That's true.
But the point is that most
people who are in this
business are very visible
and easy to get to.
But all investors have
Twitter, and
Facebook, and Google+.
And they're actually pretty
easy to get to.
That doesn't mean that they're
going to be interested or that
they'll respond.
The best way to get to investors
is to get to someone
who knows them.
So I tell startup entrepreneurs
all the time--
talk to other entrepreneurs who
have investors, and ask
them to introduce you to them.
Or talk to people who know these
VCs or these angels, and
ask for a warm introduction.
That will get you at least heard
so that you can get in
front of them.
And then your idea has to
be something that they
understand, that they're
interested in, and that looks
like a good investment.
LOUIS GRAY: So what kind of
ideas or markets are certainly
catching your eye right now?
I think maybe if it's easier,
you can go ahead and name
companies that are exciting to
you, whether you've invested
in them or not?
And if you have, let us know.
But what are the types of
markets that you think are
really taking off or are having
incredible attention?
DON DODGE: Well some of them
are fairly obvious.
I have five areas
that I look at.
So it's mobile, social,
location, games, and payments.
So it's those five areas
that are pretty hot.
But what I do is I look for
companies that have at least
two of those five elements,
and preferably three.
That gives you a little better
chance of success.
And any company today, if you
don't have a mobile component,
it's hard to imagine how you're
going to be successful.
So you've got to have mobile.
Social--
that doesn't have to be there.
But if it's a mobile, social,
location-type company, you're
hitting three of the five.
That's probably going
to be interesting.
Or if it's a mobile payments
company, that could be
interesting.
So you've got to hit at least
two of those five areas to get
my attention.
LOUIS GRAY: Now you're an
interesting guy because you've
got this different background be
it Microsoft, be it Google.
You've got database
experience.
You have a different variety
of backgrounds.
What I'll often find is what
interested me to either write
about something or to use
something, is obviously I've
got to be intrigued by the
product as something I might
want to use every day.
As we all have finite time,
the hard part is bringing
another product into your
workflow and either getting
rid of something else
or reducing time
on something else.
Do you find yourself, for
example, carrying multiple
devices and different laptops
so you can test it all?
I know I haven't seen a lot of
BlackBerry apps coming my way
recently, but for every Android
app, every once in a
while you see an iOS app.
Do you feel like you have to
carry all these different
devices just to test the
products that people want to
have you take a look at?
DON DODGE: Yeah absolutely.
I have an iPhone and
an Android phone.
I have a Mac, and I have a PC.
I have an iPad, and I have
a Samsung tablet.
So yeah, I have all these
devices, because I want to be
able to use different
things and try them.
And yes, you're right.
It is hard to get someone's
attention, to have them try
your new thing.
But remember this-- if they
can't convince you to try it
and take the time to try it,
then they're not likely to
attract the number of users
that they'll need to be
successful.
So that's a good filter.
If it doesn't excite you, and
you won't take the time to try
it out, then likely a lot of
customers won't either.
LOUIS GRAY: It's interesting.
Because I always sort of
get both directions.
You'd understand that.
But I would also get people
that almost discouragingly
say, well, Louis Gray and
Robert Scovill liked it.
That's sure to be a flop.
Because we're the
weird people.
We're the ones who are on the
edge who are constantly
connected and looking
for the new stuff.
I like being the first one
to join a network.
I like being one of the first
10 to invite my friends and
have a unique invite code
that we can send out.
We like being the cool one.
And sometimes there's a little
bit of that evangelism piece,
as you understand, that makes
you feel like you're part of
the company.
Even if you don't have shares
and even if you don't
monetarily benefit.
Like every time I read
something, for example, about
Jason Goldberg and the work
he's done with fab.com and
part of that, Fabulous.
It's like I'm a proud father
and I'm excited for his
success, because I was part of
his story with social media
and being the first to write
about that, and see him
graduate onto the next thing.
I look at Iain Dodsworth of
TweetDeck, when he got
acquired by Twitter.
Again, I get nothing from it.
But like a proud papa, I push
the baby out the door
and say, let's go.
So how do you feel about some
of that in terms of kind of
feeling a connection with the
entrepreneur, a connection
with the product, even if
you're not monetarily
compensated for your
affection?
DON DODGE: Yeah, well,
I feel the same way.
I've been in the startup world
my entire life, and I help
startups all the time that
I don't invest in.
I just help them because
it's what I like to do.
It's part of my job at Google.
And I live vicariously through
these startups
and what they do.
So I just think it's
a lot of fun.
I read Louis Gray, and Robert
Scovill, and Mike Arrington,
and all these other guys.
And I took my cues from them.
So when you wrote something
about a brand new social media
company, I would take
a look at it.
So that's another way to get
visibility and get in front of
investors, is to come to someone
like you and have you
write about them.
So it's an important part.
LOUIS GRAY: So you're saying I
should start blogging again.
I've not been doing
a great job there.
And obviously work
gets in the way.
But it's interesting.
I want to touch on one thing
before we wrap this up.
You're talking about your
role at Google.
What is it that startups and
other small or medium-sized
companies can learn from
using Google apps?
Is there something about Google
products that you think
that they should adopt
right away?
And what are those reasons?
DON DODGE: Well Google has lots
of different products
that are helpful to startups.
So its Google Apps, Gmail,
Google Maps, Search, the
location stuff.
There's all kinds of things
that people can use--
App Engine, the Compute
Engine.
So if you're doing a startup
that is cloud-based,
web-based, mobile-based
with Android--
almost any startup that you can
imagine is going to touch
something that Google does.
And most of it is easy to use,
very visible, used by hundreds
of millions of people.
And many times free
to get started.
So it's a pretty obvious
place to start.
So the Developer Relations
Group, there's
almost 200 of us now--
are out there helping startups
use Google products to get
started and help them be
successful, answer questions,
get them technology
that they need.
So it's what we do, and I think
actually the job here at
Google is much easier than
it was at Microsoft.
Convincing startups to use
Microsoft products that you
had to pay for was much, much
harder than it is to get them
to use Google products--
most of which are free, or
others start out free and you
only pay later when
you get to scale.
So it's a fun job.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
Well I definitely appreciate
you taking the
time to talk to me.
I know we'd love to have you
back in Mountain View for a
lot of this.
If I were your manager,
I'd push you to be
over here every day.
So maybe that time will come.
But I definitely appreciate you
taking the time late in
your week--
I know it's late over there
on the East Coast.
And I look forward to talking
with more of these soon.
Thanks a lot, Don.
DON DODGE: Great.
Thank you very much, Louis.